the famous I'm from The Stokes is that
it's not events that upset us it's our
opinion about events yeah and so yeah
like that's it there's another quote
it's not what happens to us that
torments us it's our thoughts about yeah
probably
the the idea that like it just is right
like like uh when I talk to like uh
hedge funds and stuff I go like you know
like a bull market and a bear Market do
not exist these are made up things that
we've come to describe a made-up thing
which is the economy like the market
doesn't exist either it's just people
doing stuff and then you've made up a
concept and then you've made up whether
it's a good version of that concept or a
bad version of that concept and then you
like pull your hair out but like it just
exists it just is it just is yeah and I
mean that's obviously you're not going
to be good at trading if you don't want
if you don't understand what these
things are but understanding that they
are abstractions should help you
actually be better at it because then
you're like oh like a hedge fund what's
difference between like a hedge fund and
you're like a value investor sure a
value investor just needs the mark to go
up but like a really great investor can
also make money when the market goes
down so it isn't there is no positive or
negative like it just it just is and you
take advantage of it one way or another
and and that's obviously easier said
than done but like it's it's the project
like I need it to be a certain way or it
should be a certain way or it's unfair
if it's a certain way that's the source
of the suffering or the distress but it
does not exist
I it's I think it's Chinese then it
might be taoism it says the great way is
not difficult for those who have no
preferences and I'm just like oh that's
the whole thing this is pulled right out
of my own thought my own brain and I've
said it before but I want to hear your
reaction to it when I there was a flight
out of Montreal it's all Comedians and
the flight was like delayed something
like six hours or something it was like
a really it was a thick delay yeah and
it was something like a 6 a.m flight or
something so we'd all none of us had
slept right so I understand some people
got mad yeah uh and I remember they were
mad at Delta and I was like again like
you with your kid I don't know why that
day Buddha Pete showed up and budapy was
like there is no Delta there's this
plane yeah sure you could argue that
noticing a pattern of reliability or
whatever and employees and a fleet of
plans yeah we agree to call it Delta but
like your bowl bear it's not it's not
not real it's just this play it's like
when you get mad and if you get mad at
the gate and you yell at this person
that is
that's like Equus thinking a horse's you
know God it's like you're just picking
one point of the thing and being like
you will be Delta yeah yeah I I try to
think too like
so that means also like okay I'm not
going to tell myself this is a bad thing
but then that also means that you have
the power to tell yourself it's a good
thing so you could be like this is a
[__] Adventure I'm like what are 200
comedians on the same delayed flight
what's that gonna look like buddy we had
a great time and we've both been alive
long enough to know you don't even
remember the flights that are on time
yeah the story is the six hour delay and
we did have a we I had fun with a lot of
those people yeah and I've taken that
flight so many times with no problem and
those are gone they're shredded as
they're happening maybe we said this
last time but I'd like to call it
Nostalgia for the president if you can
if you can somehow
the quality of nostalgia we love talking
about book titles I have that written
down as a possible that is interesting
that sounds like one of those Buddhist
things that means nothing and everything
at the same time
High Praise
[Music]